confirmado como el nuevo presidente sri
lanka Ramiro y cremesinge es una cara
vieja en un cargo nuevo tras las
protestas que derrocaron al presidente
gotabaya rayapaxa cuya familia había
dominado la política de sri lanka
durante dos décadas los legisladores
eligieron al seis veces Primer Ministro
para avanzar necesitamos continuar con
un nuevo programa lo que la gente nos
pide no son las viejas políticas el
parlamento debe unirse para enfrentar
estos asuntos
nacido en Colombia en 1949 en una
familia rica e influyente y que me finge
entró a la política en la década de 1970
como miembro del parlamento por el
partido de Unión nacional ocupó varias
carteras ministeriales y se convirtió en
Primer Ministro en 1993 a uno de sus más
recientes mandatos se le atribuyó la
transformación económica de sri lanka
aunque después su reputación quedó
dañada tras los atentados de pascua 2019
atribuidos a la autodenominado estado
islámico que dejaron más de 250 muertos
el Primer Ministro reconoció que no
atendió a tiempo las advertencias de los
servicios de inteligencia sobre posibles
ataques del grupo Los manifestantes le
reprochan a uycremesinge su cercanía con
miembros del Clan político rayapaqsa
en las elecciones de 2020 su partido
sufrió la peor derrota de su historia a
lograr solo un escaño en el parlamento
en mayo volvió a ser Primer Ministro en
medio de la crisis desde entonces ha
estado negociando un paquete de rescate
con el fondo monetario internacional
rechazado por los manifestantes
antigobernamentales a pesar de las
tensiones el líder de 73 años de edad es
ahora como presidente electo quien debe
dirigir la peor crisis económica así
como sofocar las protestas masivas que
obligaron a dimitir a su predecesor